if you want to be an entrepreneur
the most important thing
is to be customer obsessed so don't
satisfy your customers
figure out how to absolutely delight
them that is the number one thing
whoever your customers are
passion you have got to have some
passion for the arena
that you're going to
develop and work in because otherwise
you're going to be competing against
people who do have compassion for that
and they're going to build better
products and services you can't be a
mercenary you have to be a missionary
missionaries build better products and
services they always win the mercenaries
are just trying to make money
and paradoxically
the missionaries always end up making
more money to pick something that you
actually have a genuine passion for you
have to take risk
you have to be willing to take risk if
you
aren't going to take risk if you come up
with a business idea there's there's no
risk there
you're probably
you know
it's probably already being done
those ideas are already being done
they're being done well by many many
people so you've got to have something
that might not work
and so you have to accept that
your
business is going to be in many ways
an experiment and it might fail and
that's okay that's what risk is the good
news is in amazon we still take risks
all the time and we encourage it and we
talk about failure we should be feeling
our failures have to grow with the
company we need big failures if we're
going to be moving the needle we need to
have you know billion dollar scale
failures
and if we're not we're not swinging
we're not swinging hard enough hey it's
evan carmichael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to think like a
billionaire
enjoy
rule number two is use your mistakes
with oprah winfrey i know you all have
heard the phrase everybody makes
mistakes countless times in your life
and maybe even
set it to console someone and encourage
them to not dwell on a misstep
so
i'm asking today why do we let our
mistakes overshadow our good decisions
and accomplishments
what i know for sure
is that mistakes are here to help define
us and when i started the oprah winfrey
network
i definitely made some mistakes some
missteps
we launched before we were ready
and i got to tell you all if i knew then
what i know now i would have done a lot
of things differently i remember saying
at the time if i was to write a book
about it i would call it mistakes 101.
sometimes when you aren't listening to
those inner voices and the knowing of
your own purpose
you can get off track and even when i
know how to listen sometimes if i don't
listen well i get off track really
quickly you can get in the wrong
relationships or you can do things
prematurely get yourself off track
well this is what i know every perceived
mistake can be an opportunity to know
better and do better and from that
perspective there really is no such
thing as failure we may perceive it that
way in the moment but
things always turn around and eventually
leave you to the path that you're
supposed to be on if you're paying
attention
what are you here to do what are you
here to fulfill what are you here to
offer maybe it's friendship
companionship leadership maybe you're
all the ships including the mothership
that's always steering things forward
for the rest of the people in your life
well
i want you to know this for sure
life is like a wave and you ride it
through the ups and downs the steady
times and then you anchor yourself in
the storms a mistake is a life
experience designed
to move you in a different direction and
the mistake might be more important to
your supreme destiny than even a triumph
know that your life is way bigger than
anyone experience so when those mistakes
happen
you use them to guide you to the next
right move
learn from it ask what is this here to
teach me and then let it go
because you're always where you need to
be my favorite quote from eckhart
tolle's a new earth has gotten me
through many a mistake and many a storm
it says
life will give you whatever experience
is most helpful for the evolution of
your consciousness and how do you know
this is the experience you need because
this is the experience you are having at
this moment
that knowing has helped me through many
a moment so i want to ask all of you
what mistake
or mistakes have you made in your life
that you need to number one forgive
yourself for
and what mistakes turned out to be
blessings in disguise
i'd really like to hear from you and
remember it's all about progress
not about perfection because nobody's
perfect it's about
progress
so have a progressful
week rule number three learn how to take
notes with ray dalio if i'm making a
decision
that
that after i make the decision usually
or right at the time
if i pause and reflect
and i write my principle down in other
words principle is sort of a recipe what
would i use to how would i make that
decision
and what are the criteria around it i
find that i make it much more
clear it becomes clearer and it applies
to the next thing that comes along it'll
be
that way because everything happens over
and over and over again and i think
people make the mistake of looking at
just the one like it's the first one
they have i don't know they have the
first problem of this sort of the first
child or whatever it is and this has
been happening plenty of times and so if
you have the principles i found that
that helped me think more clearly about
it and it helped me communicate better
like why
and so over the years over the last 30
years or so
that's what i've done i did it
originally to communicate very well with
the people i work with
you know i set up my company and and it
was very important to have good
communication and then we could debate
the principles and so that's the process
i urge people to do that there are many
excellent decision makers um
and i just wish that they wrote down
their principles when this set
so
for example uh we talk about henry
kissinger and his new book is going to
come out with a book on leadership
um and don't just describe the leaders
describe then what about them were the
essential elements to make a good leader
under what circumstances and so if we
think about that when then also then you
begin to think in a principled way
and then when you start to think in a
principle way life becomes
it's so much easier to make decisions
and it's so much less confusing because
it's like coming up on a species and you
say okay well what species is it not
just another it's a thing no what
species is it and how do i deal with
that species effectively
and and so that's what that is and so i
encourage people to write it down i wish
anybody who's successful wrote down
their principles or their recipes for
making those types of decisions
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four focus on learning
with mark zuckerberg
one thing that facebook has done
incredibly well
is figure out what to build and be and
build this
repeated innovation culture which i
think is like the hardest thing to do in
business so how have you done that and
how do you advise other people to do the
same
i think the key
is building a company
which
is focused on learning as quickly as
possible right companies are learning
organisms
and
you can make decisions that either make
it that you learn faster or you learn
slower and you know in a lot of ways
building a company is like following the
scientific method right you try a bunch
of different hypotheses
and if you set up the experiments well
then you kind of learn what to do and
again that's that's an important
philosophy so there are all these
different decisions that we make inside
the company
you know everything down to
um really empowering individual
engineers we invest in this huge um
testing framework right at any given
point in time there aren't there's not
just one version of facebook running in
the world right there's probably tens of
thousands of versions running because
engineers here have the power
to um to try out an idea
and and and ship it to you know maybe 10
000 people or 100 000 people and then
they get a readout on how
that version of what they did whether it
was
a change to you know show better content
to news feed or or ui change or some new
feature they get a readout on how
that version performed compared to the
baseline version of facebook that we
have on everything that we care about
how how connected people are um you know
how much people are sharing and how much
they say that they're finding meaningful
content uh business metrics like how
much revenue we make and engagement of
the overall community and you know by
running tens of thousands of different
experiments and putting the power in
people's hands to try all these
different things you can imagine we just
make so much more progress than we could
if every change had to be approved by me
right or any every idea had to come from
from management so i do think there's
something very deep about building this
you know learning culture and moving
quickly towards that that just helps you
get ahead over time rule number five is
set big goals with larry page
i mean it's hard to keep things moving
and that's always a big trick i think
for me the key is setting really big
goals and uh
you know with youtube i think we've had
tremendous leadership uh
both with the founders and now with
salary has been running it
i mean i think they've all had a vision
you know to really improve people's
entertainment
improve access to entertainment build a
community
that feels really strongly about it
[Music]
that you know has free speech that has
really great diversity and you know it's
a two-way medium
and what does that mean for
entertainment and so that's kind of been
their their mission
and even how do we improve the world
given that most people
spend most of their time
engaged in entertainment you know
looking at a screen
how do we make the world better
given we have the internet
and people doing that
that's something you know you can work
the rest of your life on and be excited
about right
not just purely making money you're also
thinking about
how do i make things better
got
you know 20 or 30 hours a week of
people's time
that could really materially affect the
world right
not just make a lot of money
and so i think we're not there with
youtube yet
you know we're
10 minutes or something out of the
40 hours
so you see the potential for business
growth
and you see the potential to do
something
new and different
and you have a great pace to build on
that
but in my experience with these things
is you kind of get stuck
you know you're a car company you make
cars
uh you know you look at tesla i mean i'm
friends with elon
you know they're a car company with a
mission to change the world and make it
zero emissions
you know that's a mission you can
get further on than just being a normal
car company
and again from peter's talk
you know technology is with you they've
got a
30 year 10 percent better
heavier batteries to work with
and you know i had car engines don't get
better
uh traditional ones
so i think
a lot of times my issue is people are
not setting
goals
that will
be something that somebody who becomes
rich or could do anything
you got to be excited about working on
that for 10 years
so you got to have a big enough goal
that you know you attract the best
people and you retain them
and you keep them focused
and then my experience you don't go
wrong you know maybe you don't hit it
next year
or maybe you fail entirely and you
discover something more exciting to work
on
with the same set of people i'm rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus clips is think about the
point of impact with michael dell what
advice would you give to entrepreneurs
in terms of managing those very dramatic
and different stages within their
company's growth you know you have to
think about the
the the point of impact
if you're running a business with a
hundred people
uh the point of impact for the leader is
very different than if it's a thousand
people or ten thousand or hundred
thousand
and so
that's the frame of reference that that
i've always used is to say okay
if i'm leading this organization what
are the things that actually i can do
to cause it to be successful if it's a
thousand people it's very very different
than it is for me today so today i'm a
lot more focused on strategy because
that's the point of impact
on 110 000 person company 100 person
company you know you're sort of doing
any job in the organization you're doing
every job in the organization you know
potentially and that might be okay at
that point as a business grows the
natural tendency would be to
take fewer risks and to be cautious and
to have contingency plans but in a
business that's changing very quickly or
one that you want to grow
you actually need to
be explicit about accepting risk
one of the uh
people who work with me kind of
described it this way they you know i
was sort of encouraging this person hey
you know let's try this why don't we do
this how about this and at some point he
kind of came back and said so what
you're telling me is you want me to try
to do 10 things and if i only get eight
of them
you know you'll be okay with that you
know if i don't get all you know all 10
versus
you know having five things and doing
all five perfectly that's exactly right
you know you know we we want to accept
some experiments just like every other
venture they're not all going to work
but in the context of a large company we
can actually define some very healthy
risk appetite
that is very productive in terms of our
future growth
rejection leads to success all you have
to do is look at the people that you
look up to look at the people that i
profiled on my youtube channels and what
you'll find is rejection after rejection
after rejection so rejection lead to
success you know this intellectually you
already know this but when you get into
the situation where you have to face
rejection then your emotions take over
your fears take over and you don't do
the thing that you might get rejected
for even though you know logically
because in that moment your emotions
your fear are greater than your logic i
had a life-changing fear of rejection
situation happened to me in paris when i
was 18 years old and i was there when i
was on a street outside the notre dame
cathedral and i had a map in front of me
and this cute girl comes up to me she
asks for directions and i wanted to ask
her out and i was too afraid i was too
embarrassed i was too ashamed i was too
worried that i might get rejected in my
head the only thing i could think of was
i wanna ask her out
and
she might reject me she might say no and
so what did i do nothing
now
if i had logically stood to the side
press timeout you know pause the
situation say evan logically what makes
sense logically you know she might say
no
and you're okay you'll move on with the
rest of your day logically she might say
yes why is why is she coming up to you
asking for directions why is she asking
for directions when she already speaks
perfect french and she seems like a
local
right logically that's what makes the
most sense logically i should have
summoned the courage to go off and do it
but in the moment
your emotions take over your fear takes
over that idea that you might get
rejected takes over and so what did i do
nothing
i let her walk away
and ever since that day
i reminded myself that i would rather
know and fail than not know
and i use that painful moment to
whenever i am thinking about doing
something i'm afraid of rejection for
afraid of it not working out then i have
to do it that that moment is what led me
to become an entrepreneur
because a year later when i had the
chance to have my dream job and make
100k a year travel around the world or
be an entrepreneur on 30 of a business
and make 300 a month
i had that picture in my head
where i was thinking i can't let this
happen again i don't want to live with
regret i would rather know and fail than
not know
and that gave me the courage to keep
going
so i know you guys know this
i know you know it intellectually i know
every success story that you read is
motivating as inspiring to you and you
see other rejections
but then when you get faced with it when
you're face to face
with that fear
tend to play small you tend to do the
thing that you're not proud of and then
you tend to live with regret so how do
you get rid of it how do you get through
that tough situation that fear of
rejection and not let your emotions take
over i'm gonna give you a three-step
strategy that will help step number one
is create a stronger negative emotion
so people say be fearless i don't i
don't think you can i think i think if
you're living a great life you should be
constantly doing things that you're
afraid of
right if you have no fear
then it means you're doing something
that
is normal that is inside your comfort
zone you're photocopying your life over
and over and over again so it's not be
fearless it's when you are afraid of
something at least for me
create a stronger negative emotion which
is regret
so here's what i would do the next time
you're in that moment you're afraid to
do something right fear of rejection is
creeping up
imagine yourself as a 95 year old you're
in an old age home you're sitting on
your rocking chair and and life is
almost over for you and you think about
the past x number of years decades
between where you are now where you are
95 and this moment right now was the
thing that would change your life for
the better forever
and because you were too afraid you
spend your entire life regretting not
doing it because you very rarely regret
the things that you do it's the things
not done that you regret
and so you've just spent the past x
number of decades
in regret
hating your life because you didn't do
the thing
and at least for me that creates enough
pain that i have to do the thing
and so you create a stronger negative
emotion you don't overcome emotions with
logic in the moment when you're very
emotional you overcome emotion with a
stronger emotion and the easier way to
do it is to go negative
and so the pain that you're about to
face is very real i just create a much
bigger pain so it forces me to action
just like if you have a hangnail it
hurts but if you punch yourself in the
arm or somebody hits you you don't feel
this anymore because this hurts too much
so create that pain of regret a future
regret that if you don't do this thing
you're gonna hit your life forever and
so now you're able to do that small
thing that small scary thing
and face possible rejection
strategy number two is create a stronger
positive emotion so instead of going
negative you go positive now i love
going positive but i find the negative
actually works better in these acute
situations but net i want to be positive
so the positive solution is i want to be
a hero you want to be a hero you want to
be strong you tell yourself that you're
strong for doing these things that
you're a hero for doing these things
that you're getting stronger that you're
building muscle
that that you do scary things
that you're afraid of rejection that
that's not a good enough reason that you
do scary things because you are a hero
because you're on a mission because
you're going to change the world because
you're going to have a huge impact
and that means you have to do it so it's
not trying to fight it logically because
logic won't work again logic doesn't
work against an emotional situation you
need stronger emotion to combat the
emotion so just saying well they
probably won't reject me or what's the
worst that's going to happen is not as
powerful as i am a hero
i do difficult things i face rejection i
risk things not working out i risk
humiliation and i get through it because
i am a hero
so step one is go negative step two is
go positive and then step three is
expect to suck and tie yourself forth to
the effort one of the big problems
people have is you tie your self-worth
to the outcome that if you don't get a
yes then you suck as a human you expect
to be great and then when you're not
great you hate yourself right and then
you expect to win
and when you don't win you hate yourself
this is this is why people don't have
self-confidence self-respect self-love
because they tie their self-worth to the
result
where you want to do the opposite you're
going to go do this thing that you've
never done before and you're going to
suck at it like everything else you've
done that you've never done before it
doesn't mean you suck as a human you
just don't have the skills yet because
it's the very first time that you've
done it
and then you tie your self-worth what
you love about yourself where your
confidence pulls from to the fact that
you were willing to try
not to that you won
because tying your self-worth to winning
means you only do things that you're
going to win at means you play small for
life where if you tie yourself forth to
i'm gonna try things that will risk
failure that will risk rejection
then your life will grow exponentially
because you're not worried about hitting
the outcome you're worried about the
growth
you're worried about you building you
learning you're growing as a human and
if every day you're off doing things
that you're proud of your effort for i
guarantee you your life will look
dramatically different one year from
today so try it one create a stronger
negative emotion two create a stronger
positive emotion and three expect to
suck and tie your self-worth to the
effort not the results stop thinking
that you should be fearless if you go
through life fearless that means you are
playing small and not doing anything
that is worth doing you should be
dreaming big you should be pushing
boundaries and in that push comes fear
instead of trying to be fearless adopt
the mindset that you want to feel the
fear and do it anyway otherwise you will
never take on big projects and you'll
never accomplish your mission and you'll
always live below the potential that you
know you're capable of if you are doing
something new you are going to get
rejected if you're doing something that
you're not good at yet you're going to
get rejected if you're doing something
that goes against the status quo
you are going to get rejected so you
have two choices live a life with zero
growth and never get rejected or chase
your dream
deal with the rejection that comes and
go change the world i have rejection all
the time in my life from little
rejections of making videos that don't
pop to bigger rejections of projects
that i care deeply about that just don't
fly and people don't accept at the
beginning when i first started as a
broadcaster i was 19 very insecure
thrown into television
pretending to be barbara walters looking
nothing like her and
still going to college so i do all my
classes in the morning from eight to one
and then the afternoon i work from two
to ten
and did the six o'clock news
and
would stay up and study and all that
stuff you know until one two or three
o'clock in the morning and then just
start the routine all over again
and my classmates were so jealous of me
that i remember like taking my little
hundred and fifteen dollar paycheck
and um
at the time i thought it was really a
lot but taking 115 and trying to appease
them i would like always anytime anybody
needing money i was always offering oh
you need ten dollars or taking them out
for pizza ordering pizza for the class
and things like that trying to that
whole disease to please that's where it
was the worst for me i think because i
wanted to be accepted by them and could
not be because first of all i didn't
have the time they wanted wanted me to
pledge and i didn't have the time to
pledge i was i didn't have the time to
be a part of all the other college
activities or a part of that whole
lifestyle and it was very difficult for
me socially really one of the worst
times of my life because i was trying to
fit in
in school and be a part of that culture
but also trying to build a career in
television it's very difficult for me to
even
see myself as successful because i still
see myself as in the process of becoming
successful to me successful is getting
to the point where you are absolutely
comfortable with yourself
and
it does not matter how many things you
have acquired
the ability to learn to say no and not
to feel guilty about it to me is about
the greatest success i have achieved
the fact that i have you know in the
public side done whatever
is fine
it's all a part of a process for for
growing for me but to me to have the in
the kind of internal strength and
internal courage it takes to say no i
will not let you treat me this way
is what success is all about it's the
same thing that prevents you from being
abused as a child that prevents you from
being abused as an adult that allows you
to build success for yourself i will not
be treated this way i demand
only the best for myself
you are worthy to say no you were that
it's okay if you say no it's okay if you
say no and then people don't like you
that's really okay the important thing
is
how you feel about what you're doing how
you feel about yourself
it's a long struggle though
it's a long struggle and i'm just hoping
that you know in the work that i do on
the show
and the speaking that i do around the
country and that young people who are
watching this can get the lesson sooner
than i did because it's painful because
you keep repeating it over and over and
over until you get it right and what i
found is that every time you have to
repeat the lesson it gets worse because
it's you know it's i i call it god
trying to get your attention the
universe trying to get your attention so
we didn't get your attention the first
time so we're gonna have to hit you a
little harder this time so
i'm still doing it i'm still learning
running your own race demands trusting
yourself even when others don't because
guess what there are a lot of people
good people people who love you who
trust you and who you love and trust
who want the best for you
and you'll come to them with some ideas
about what you want to do and how you
want to do it and they're going to say
that's crazy
just like when i left my first
engineering job
at kraft and was telling my grandfather
i was going back to business school and
he said that's a great paying job that's
crazy
and when i finished business school and
decided to join the tumultuous world of
investment banking
my friends and my family and my spoke up
with concerns about my sanity
and when i left goldman sachs right
after we'd gone public
to set up a private equity firm called
vista
my mentors and colleagues at goldman
sachs thought i was crazy
and to top it all off when i told i'm
going to start a firm we're going to
focus on enterprise software
and not be diversified like all other
private equity firms i was going to hire
a team of smart young talented people
who'd never done this before
everyone knew i was certifiable
and i did this of course in the spring
of 2000 about two months before the
entire tech bubble crashed well all i
can tell you is i've never been mad at
these folks in fact i'm
grateful for the advice and their
concern
because in their caution i found my
courage
in their doubts i found my resolve
and in their warning warnings i found my
voice and chartered my own journey
and i'm proud of the vista story we take
risks we do things differently and we
listen to our own voice we run our own
race and it has worked
we are now considered to be the number
one private equity firm on the planet
and have been so for the last decade
everything i did i was following
something i really cared about something
i loved something i was passionate about
and i kept following that passion
whether it was cars
whether it was anthropology
whether it was art
photography
and eventually it led me
to my huge passion my real passion which
was making movies which combined all of
those things and i realized that had i
gone on to get my degree in anthropology
i would have probably made
anthropological movies in new guinea or
someplace and eventually been on
national geographic and you know the
history channel and
uh
been then making features and i had done
star wars just the same if i'd gone to
art center and become an illustrator i
would have probably started doing
animation and doing animated films and
making animated things and then
ultimately i would have gone on and been
right where i was so no matter which
route i took
because i cared about all of them they
all led to the same place
had i done what my father had wished me
to do which is to go into these
office equipment business with him which
i knew i wasn't going to do i knew i
hated that
my life would have been
unpleasant
and
so i think it's very important not to do
what your um peers think
you should do not do what your parents
think you should do or your teachers but
to do what you inside or even your
culture thinks but do what's inside you
i would
i would like to tell you of
two women
uh
that
each sold the business
to berkshire hathaway
uh to me actually for many many many
millions of dollars
both of them started with 2 500
by a coincidence was the exact same
amount it was everything they had in the
world
and one of them
was a woman
who landed in seattle in 1917
speak a word of english
had a tag around her neck
the tag said
fort dodge iowa
the red cross
got her to fort dodge where she was
reunited with her husband who had come
to the country a couple of years earlier
and she lived in fort dodge for two
years
and as she put it
she felt like a dummy
she couldn't pick up the language she
couldn't learn a word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided
to move to omaha
so they came to omaha
in 1919
and there she found a small colony of
russian jews so she started feeling more
at home
and then as her oldest daughter went to
school
she would come home this daughter
francis
and she would teach her mother the words
she learned in school that day
and this woman rose bumpkin
spent 20 years
saving money
bringing first her siblings
over her mother and father
fifty dollars at a time she sold used
clothing to do it
she had four children during this period
and by 1937 after 20 years
save 2 500
she went to chicago
and she bought what she could have
furniture her dream had always been to
open
a furniture store
and this woman without who had never
gone to school one day in her life
with 2 500
but with the same spirit that the people
in this room had
about having a dream
and working to accomplish that dream
she built a business
which she
sold to me
in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin
lived
while she she worked for me until she
was 103
and
then
saying then she retired and she died the
next year which is a lesson to all the
berkshires managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs b
with her twenty five hundred dollars
one further fact about her
she could not read or write
and she went into a furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew that she cared about her
customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this incredible business my
father-in-law once gave me this advice
he was the first person i met that had
really been successful and he said
what you want to do
is know more about any situation than
anyone else in the world
and i actually remember what i said to
him i said yeah my boss doesn't really
think like that
i have since apologized to my
father-in-law for giving me such an
amazing piece of information and me
doing nothing with it for like six years
but once i understood that the only path
to excellence is to truly become an
expert the only path to excellence is to
actually get good at something
these days in a hyper-connected world
where within minutes of an interaction
with you your product whatever someone
can have a global audience and tell
people what they think that product
better be awesome
but the great news is the world's been
democratized now
you no longer have to have
150 million dollar ad budget in order to
cut through the clutter
in our first eight months we were
profitable at month six in our first
eight months we didn't invest more than
ten thousand dollars
because we had a product that actually
delivered value
our marketing message delivered value
and if you focus on that if you focus on
making something that's better than what
other people are doing now you really
can cut through the noise very very
quickly
and you gotta grind baby grind
that was me for almost two years
people see where the company's gotten
they see me up giving speeches but what
they don't see is that in the middle of
the night my hands used to wake me up
cramping closed
because all day i was making protein
bars and in the very beginning we were
running the technology company during
the day and then going and making
protein bars by hand at night with
rolling pins and handheld blades that we
cut the bars and then wrapped them three
at a time we wrapped them three at a
time we would make 1200 bars i think
nine of us made 1200 bars over a six or
seven hour period now in a day we make
1.5 million
but that's where it starts it starts
with the willingness
to persist
long after it's boring it starts with
the ability to focus on your end
customer long after you're exhausted it
starts with the ability to think about
those people that you really want to
serve when you're scared and have no
idea how you're going to pull it off
but you chose to believe
that you could do it you chose to
believe that and because you chose to
believe that you were able to achieve
excellence i'll ask you a very simple
question
why does your organization
exist
we don't need you clearly there's plenty
of competition clearly people have
plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do a reasonably
good job they might even be better than
you in some areas so why do you exist
providing education is table stakes
everybody here does that you can't rely
on that that's why the industry exists
not why your organization exists
that's like when i talk to healthcare
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy like no kidding
thank you but i know that the culture of
one organization is different than the
culture of another organization
there are cultural norms that wrap
around the sense of purpose cause or
belief
great organizations understand their
just cause a cause so just
that people would be willing to
sacrifice to see the advancement of that
cause sacrifice comes in many forms it
might mean
working longer hours giving you my best
ideas turning down a better job that
offers me more money to stay here
because i believe in what you're doing
and i want to see that advanced
one of my favorite
examples of a just cause
is
the declaration of independence
our founding fathers
declared literally wrote down they
declared why
we needed our own country
all men are created equal
endowed with these unalienable rights
amongst which include life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
they were never against britain
the whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
they won independence there are always
finite games within the infinite game
though they won independence
that didn't mean that they had now
provided all men are equal now the real
heavy lifting began
now let's be crystal clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white protestant men let's be
crystal clear
but even early on during the
revolutionary war
george washington understood how
limiting that was and he realized that
they had to have a broader definition
so he included catholics
he banned any organizing against
catholics and his armies and he would
regularly attend mass to send the right
message
some time later
we abolished slavery
and the 14th amendment
some time later we had women suffrage
sometime later we had
civil rights act some time later we
implement gay rights and you can see
that we are striving to provide this
thing called all men are equal people
are equal and though we will never
actually get there we will die trying
and the obstacles may always be
different
and what a just cause is
it is a vision of the future that does
not yet exist and you will commit all of
your energies
to advance that vision of the world that
you have
and the people you want to attract both
those who work there those who teach
there and both those who come to learn
there believe in your vision of the
future
so much so
that they may turn down a better offer
from someone else
because they want to be
around people
who are committed to building this world
that does not yet exist and every single
single one of these organizations that
you
run and represent
can have different visions or
overlapping visions of the world but you
must be clear what your just cause is
what you stand for otherwise the only
thing i have to judge you on
is
superficial things
it's like dating right
it's like dating if if somebody tells me
what they stand for who they are they're
talking about their character
and those are the people we want to
spend the rest of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are
what they stand for what their purpose
what their cause what their beliefs are
what their values are
the only thing we have to judge them on
is how much money they make and how good
looking they are you're running you're
ceo of two companies you're chairman of
solar city
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep
uh
yeah sometimes not enough sleep is
really great uh because
because if you i find if i don't get
enough sleep then i'm i'm quite grumpy
um
i mean obviously i think most people are
that way
and and also
like i try to sort of figure out what's
the right amount of sleep
because like i found i could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it i would get
less done because
my mental acuity would be affected
um so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours on average per night um that's not
too bad yeah right and any other tips on
average though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously i mean do
you do you find i mean i know you're up
here monday tuesday is it all tesla when
you're up in silicon valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a
sort of
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email during um interstitial periods
like you're in a car you're walking in
the bathroom everywhere you can do email
practically when you're awake
and uh
and so that's really helpful to have
email for spacex and tesla integrated on
my phone
and then uh
and then just you have to apply a lot of
hours to actual working actually working
so the way i generally do it is i'll be
uh
working at spacex
on monday and then monday night flight
to the bay area
uh
spent tuesday
and wednesday at the bay area
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night spend thursday and
friday
at spacex um in in the last several
months then i would fly back here on a
saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
uh or
spend saturday at tesla and sunday at
spacex i talk a lot about
willingness to be misunderstood that's a
really important thing to have if you're
going to do anything new or different in
the world it is going to be
misunderstood sometimes by
well-meaning critics sometimes by
self-interested critics you'll get all
kinds
and
it's okay
it's all part of the process the only
way to avoid criticism altogether
is to be completely conventional in
everything you do
and
so how do you respond to the criticism
what do you do what's the right thing to
do
well i think
the first thing you do
is you ask
are the critics right you listen you ask
are they right or even if they're not
completely right
is there some piece of it that's right
that you can be inspired by
and then if you decide by the way that
the answer is no that you believe you
have conviction that what you're doing
is the right course
then no force in the world should be
able to move you
you should have a deep keel
but
if you decide that your critics that
there is something
then you should change
um and
i give you an example from the early
days of amazon of one where we refused
to change this we were small enough that
most people didn't pay much attention to
us or care about us i'm taking you way
back to like 1995 1996
we pioneered this thing called customer
reviews
and i got a letter one day from a
publisher
a book publisher that said hey
um you must not understand your business
you're losing sales because you're
allowing negative customer reviews
on
the book detail pages why don't you just
put positive reviews
and i thought about this and i thought
no
he's wrong we don't make money when we
sell things we make money when we help
people make purchase decisions
it was a different framing
and so
getting to today's news
you know we listened to our critics and
we decided
the framing that we have been using all
these years is
competitive compensation we look at what
other job opportunities there are and
what the competitive compensation levels
are and we offer competitive
compensation and actually
non-competitive world leading benefits
packages but just competitive
compensation
and
so
in light of this you know we're thinking
about this and trying to decide do we
want to change
we realize we just made a decision well
you can offer competitive competition or
you can decide to lead
and as soon as we framed it that way
we're like let's decide to lead it's
like i think people will follow and what
was it the critics said that caught your
eye
basically they were saying
they were if you read between the lines
because a lot of the specific criticism
was not correct but if you read between
the lines what they really wanted us to
do they said because you could also say
look there's so many companies all the
fast food companies there's you know the
baristas and there's you know wait wait
a second why
are you focusing on us but that what
they're really saying is we're focusing
on you because you're a leader
and we want you to lead
that's what they're actually saying and
as soon as you recognize it that way
instead of it feeling like criticism it
feels empowering they're asking us to
lead because we're a symbol of
an innovative
iconic company we're a gold standard for
innovation
we should lead when you get a 1 000 on
your sat i probably got like a 980. i've
convinced myself that i broke a thousand
creativity becomes a survival skill it's
a necessity to get into the door to
interview to sell everything for me
revolved around creativity so one day at
the recording studio i walk in and
there's a cassette sitting on the music
board and it's the cassette that changed
my life
the cassette was by an artist a rat
pioneer named dana dane dana was a
brooklyn-born artist his first album was
one of my favorite albums and this was
an advanced copy in the late 80s that
nobody
nobody had
sitting there i wanted to listen to it
so i asked the engineer if i could
borrow the cassette and i would bring
the cassette back after i listened to it
he said sure
a couple of days later i'm on my way to
los angeles to visit a friend i'm
listening to it in my sony walkman if
anyone remembers those sony walkman yeah
and when i'm on the plane i read that
the owner of delicious finals favorite
artist this is a big label tone lok and
young his favorite artist is dana dane
so when i land in california i cold
called delicious vinyl i get all the way
up to the assistant of this guy she has
no idea what i'm talking about i'm
talking very fast like a new yorker i
have dana's tape i know mike's a fan of
dana dana
she puts me on hold
she comes back two minutes later and she
says dana
if you can be here at two o'clock mike
ross would love to meet you
dana will be there at two o'clock
two o'clock comes the dana's a
brooklyn-born guy like i said
african-american goldtooth
not me
i pushed the
now a good friend of mine though
push the button they said i said hey i'm
dana here from micros oh
mike is expecting you dana come right in
i walk in they escort me into the office
loc's record young's record he's got
this funky candle going they sit me down
i'm sitting there i'm waiting no idea
what's going to happen in walks
mike ross
and says to me not as politely who in
the world are you there's a famous quote
by harry truman if you can't convince
them
confuse them
it works so far
so i start saying oh i work at the same
studio as dana i know you're a fan of
dana he must be late he has an advanced
tape bubble can i put in my cassette
that i did at dana studio you have a
cassette what do you do
i wrap
huh put it in
put in my cassette and he says the four
words that every artist struggling
artist wants to hear
who's your lawyer
i don't have a lawyer i have a dad so i
give him my dad's number my dad owns a
plumbing
my dad owns a plumbing supply house in
mineola
i call my father when we leave i said
dad i think i just got a record deal if
someone calls you
we got our foot in the door we're gonna
figure the rest out later get all the
documents
that started a journey of getting my
foot in the door
and figuring it out later a key thing in
creativity starting the process trusting
the process and letting it evolve
because if you don't get your foot in
the door if you don't start
nothing happens i did it with a company
called marquee jet we sold it to warren
buffett i did it with our company's eco
coconut water we sold it to coca-cola
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know the daily routines of
billionaires check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there 996
is the spirit that i encouraging alipapa
people if you want to have a bright
future
if you don't want to be
give up by the society